we're getting a first look inside the
newest airliner to take flight in the
u.s. next month Delta will debut its
brand new Airbus a 220 on routes linking
New York to Boston and dallas-fort worth
passengers will find the plane breaks
with an unpopular trend by offering
wider seats it also comes with a new
system to avoid turbulence Kris Van
Cleave takes us on board at Delta's
Technical Operations Center at
hartsfield-jackson Atlanta International
Airport you could say the Airbus a 220
was slow to take off it started as a
plane no one seemed to want but now
Delta is betting it's the jet you're
gonna want to fly on the reason
passengers should care about the a220
are three magical words wieder coach
seats
you don't hear airlines introducing
planes that are actually much more
comfortable for us as travelers
especially in coach seats eyes is a
common complaint with fliers the 18
point six inch wide seats are the
largest economy seats in Delta's fleet
and come as Congress has mandated the
FAA to determine a minimum safe seat
size on planes the 109 seat a 220 boasts
bigger overhead bins so your bag is
going to fit larger windows in seat
power and TV screens and it's the only
airliner we know of that has a loo with
a view yep
that's a window in the bathroom you're
in 35,000 feet it has a shade but what a
view
Tim Mapes is Delta's chief marketing
officer we want to bring a luxury a
sense of style and a sense of excitement
back to travel and something that
somebody can look forward to and perhaps
as opposed to dread the flight deck is
state-of-the-art and includes an app to
avoid turbulence Delta's flight weather
viewer aims to show pilots where the
smooth air is by crowdsourcing data from
all of Delta's aircraft fly me up and
down front
smooth air I can look at this and say
yeah if it's right there I don't
if the focus on the inside is comfort
out here it's about efficiency the plane
is made of composite material so it's
lighter and those engines are new and
advanced making the plane 20% more
fuel-efficient basically it flies
farther for cheaper the a220 was
designed by Canadian jet maker
Bombardier but struggled to win orders
and prompted a trade dispute with Boeing
until Airbus bought the plane and plan
to move some production to the u.s.
Delta ordered 75 and JetBlue another 60
which will have the new plane flying
high over the US for years to come for
CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave Atlanta
I don't know if I need the window in the
bathroom but okay that's great I love
the idea it's like ways for pilots with
that turbulence track or maybe they can
add it up very cool and I appreciate
that they're doing something for Coach
because every time I got in a plane
first class just seems more luxurious
and I just keep on walking first-class
is a different world very proud of Delta
this morning that's my artist me too as
well